all right so this is gonna be a surprise
for graham this is the first time we've
ever done this where
graham has no idea who the guest on the
podcast is i'm really excited i've kept
a great secret
do you have anything to say i have no
idea i have no clue
under promise and over deliver is
usually a motto i like to go by
uh hello hello hello graham hey
do you have any idea yet we keep talking
how's it going
good to be here d'angelo wallace
you got it there you go
no way yup hey welcome to the 54th ever
episode of the ice coffee hour podcast
my name is d'angelo wallace and so far
podcast has made hundred and forty 66
dollars and eighty cents oh
that was awesome the best one so far he
loved it
that was awesome what a surprise
d'angelo hey i'm just glad to be here
thank you so much for doing this how did
this
come about how did you how did this
happen we have the same sponsor agent
mary mary yep wow
was it was this mary's doing i asked her
the other the other people that she
she she does brand deals for and uh
d'angelo came up and i said wow like i'm
a fan of d'angelo and i know graham
loves his content as well so
i'm just surprised that he i mean you're
so gracious to come on here he's so kind
to come on here
oh no i'm just you know nobody has much
going on nowadays
i enjoy talking to people i'm just
excited to see what we're gonna get into
today
well thank you so much man have you seen
our content before all of this
or not so much um actually i am familiar
with your channel specifically because
of
one video you made i don't remember the
exact title
but i show it to my actual
the people in my life it was about how
much you're making from youtube or
something along those lines and in it
you kind of get into specifics about how
you got started
and how you were working a full-time job
but doing youtube full-time at the same
time and i actually related to a lot of
things in that video
just because the way i got started has
similar
origins in terms of me having to make it
my full-time job even though it wasn't
paying me like that so
yeah i actually really appreciate the
content you put out and even when people
don't like
necessarily get what i'm saying like no
anyone can do youtube
from any stage you just gotta put stuff
into it and things will come out of it i
show them that video
that's awesome man well thank you how
did you get started because
i saw your video what was it what was it
the the moment was it the moment shane
dawson's career and
what what was the title the exact moment
what was the taurus
um the exact moment shane dawson's
career ended and then
a time stamp how did you think very
direct how did you think of that title
well honestly i'm gonna be frank i just
need people to click
so i figured instead of you know fluff
or anything like that
it would just be like a headline style
title because now i've made it a
definitive statement so you kind of got
to see
why exactly i think it's thus wow how
did you get started
um i started youtube well for context
i've been creating videos since
before i ever uploaded them to youtube
like when i was 13 years old
we had this horrifyingly slow computer
in the hallway it would crash with you
loaded up
windows movie maker i'm not sure how
that works but i would use it to make
like little fake commercials and stuff
like that and then i wound up going to
school for mass communication with a
concentration in digital film and
television production
so i was still making videos um all
throughout my teenage years and then
into adulthood
and then finally in 2018 i want to say
it
was
2017 and 2018 i would have to check i
uploaded a video
with audio narration to youtube and that
happened to take off for me
and from there i've been through a
couple of niche changes
but it's been all up i guess the rest is
history for me
wow how did you get into the uh i don't
want to say that
the drama niche but commentary yeah how
did you fall into that
yeah drama t commentary all of that
stuff i really just talk about it
because it mirrors
conversations that i have outside of
youtube i feel like the best youtube
videos are when you can tell
if that person was right in front of you
they would just say the exact same thing
so all the things like my friends
or i would come to me and ask me about
like hey do you know what's going on
with this and i would be like
yeah actually i do know what's going on
with that i started
just um putting them into video format
just because
i enjoy analyzing situations i enjoy
breaking things down
i especially enjoy looking for angles
where maybe
i can use a trending topic to make a
larger point about something that's been
weighing on me for a while so
i would say it was a natural progression
just if you look at kind of where i
wound up in the commentary space but i'm
pretty grateful because people do seem
to enjoy the videos
how long do they take you to make
because i'm watching these videos
and it's like an hour long of super
well researched i know and thank you i
never watch video rarely do i watch the
video more than like 20 minutes
rarely but for me to put on a video
watch it in regular speed for an entire
hour says a lot
and it's like it's what's watching a m
it's like it's a movie
how long has it like walk us through
that process of creating a video like
that like how do you come up with the
topic
do you how do you plan it out how do you
gather information how do you edit it
like just
everything i'm intrigued well
i would say everything is reverse
engineered
starting with um audience retention
like before i think about click-through
rate
or anything like that the most important
thing to me is like
if i'm going to be putting this much
work into a video how am i going to make
sure that people are actually watching
the video
so i would say the reason people kind of
get like you know docu vibes or things
like that from my videos is because
i absolutely always adhere to a
three-act structure even if i don't
necessarily verbalize that or lampshade
that in the video
all the long videos i've uploaded
recently i've
written the synopsis i treat the um
people i'm talking about
as if they're characters in the story
because we all are at the end of the day
i just try to make sure i'm telling the
most accurate version of that
and then i instead just tried to present
the video as if it was
something you might find on netflix
instead of just some dude ranting
in his room and then for um laughs i add
all the rants back in
after i make sure that all of my
information is correct and the structure
is good enough to facilitate actually
sitting through
a one hour video so i would say in terms
of how long that takes me
i might get the initial idea for a video
a couple months before i actually start
working on it
just because there's a lot of people
watching the videos i've gotta make sure
it's not a situation that's gonna
randomly change details halfway through
and then you know leave me with egg on
my face
so once i've actually locked in a topic
which might take a few weeks
it's relatively straightforward i draft
up the outline
i make sure the synopsis is solid and
from there to the day it goes live it
could be anywhere from
three weeks to maybe a month and a half
or so like for example
one of my videos or rather the most
recent video i uploaded on that channel
was about um you know cover 19 and a lot
of interesting things that influencers
are doing
yes and i would say that videos when i
got the idea for
a couple months before i actually got
into it and then the process of it took
maybe a month and a half two months or
so but yeah i try i try not to linger on
things too much just because
perfectionism is not what's going to
drive the algorithm forward
instead i just try to make sure i'm
factual and entertaining
wow so when you're planning through
something like that
what happens if you're not in the mood
don't you have to be
like just inspired about a topic to
really get that like
authenticity and excitement coming
through absolutely
uh i have scrapped entire video topics
ones that i have put a lot of work into
just because i feel like
the easiest thing like a lot of people
don't necessarily know what goes into a
youtube video right there's a bit of
magic
a bit of things that get left unsaid
between the viewer
and the youtuber but i feel like one
thing that you can't really hide
is if you're watching someone who
doesn't actually care about what they're
saying
that is just i feel like it comes
through from the very first sentence of
a video so
even if i start feeling for a moment
like you know what
i actually don't think that this is
worth talking about
for this long i started i tried to make
it work it didn't pan out
i will scrap the video topic i would say
i've done that two major times because
obviously that's not great for business
but there was just two times when i was
like this seems like something that
would get views
this is definitely something i could
turn into a good video
but that being said i just don't see
myself being able to bring the same
level that i have in previous videos and
so
i'm really not afraid to let time pass
between uploads i know that's the one
thing you've got to be consistent
so i have my other channel for that
where i'm very consistent but as far as
the channel with the longer uploads
if it takes me a couple months to make
sure i have something that's worth
watching i'll take that just because
i know the um ratios are so high in that
channel specifically because people know
i'm not there to waste my time
so i'm not going to waste their time
either what are the two videos you
scrapped
one of them was about uh
it was just supposed to be this magnum
opus about
kids channels not the cool ones that
like you know my little
family members watch but the awful ones
that you know use their platform for
wrong
and like even though i had edited the
intro and i
found somebody to sponsor a video with
such a dark topic
and i had hyped it up a little bit i was
just starting to realize
hey this is actually a little bit
depressing a little just a tad
depressing
i don't want to make a one hour video
about the worst of the worst so
i kind of just put that one on the shelf
you never know
the outline's so good maybe i'll come
back to it if i just
feel the need um and then i would say
the other major video i scrapped
was just supposed to be a surprise
follow-up
to one of um the videos i uploaded
but halfway through i was like you know
what i don't think we need a part two i
said everything that i meant
in the first video so we're just gonna
move forward and there's always new
things to cover anyway
but first i want to thank our sponsor
stamps.com are you still making those
long and cumbersome trips to the post
office while blasting that nickelback
album that was released in 2005
well it is time to eliminate the trip to
the post office and stop paying full
price for postage with stamps.com that's
right aside from the time savings you
get with stamps.com you can get
discounts up to 40
off post office rates and up to 66 off
ups shipping rates stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups
right to your computer it is a must-have
for any business with all that saving
it's almost like turning your computer
into jerome powell's money printer for
your business but seriously stamps.com
is a no-brainer and that is exactly why
nearly 1 million small businesses
already use it with the ability to print
postage 24 7 for any letter or package
right from your computer stop wasting
time going to the post office and go to
stamps.com instead there is no risk and
with my promo code ich you get special
offers that include a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
and there's no long-term commitment or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in ich
that's stamps.com promo codeich
stamps.com never go to the post office
ever again thank you so much stamps.com
for sponsoring this episode and back to
the podcast
that's fair enough are you want to go
yeah quick question
how helpful were your college studies in
like photography and video and stuff
like that
to creating these like amazing hour-long
youtube documentaries
thank you well i'll say this
i learned a lot in college about how to
write and
i feel like writing is like my secret
superpower no one really thinks about it
too much but that is the backbone of
everything i've posted that's like over
a certain
time frame is just my writing ability
which i'm trying to hone day in and day
out
i'll even write things and then not turn
them into videos just so i can get that
practice
but that's it anything that you see
visually like even right now my bright
setup i've got kind of like
this daylight emulation thing going on
and
you know what are my angles and what
equipment do i need
to use and why does everything sound so
crisp i got all that from youtube
so i try not to be bitter about it
because i'm like you know what no it's
fine
i learned how to write in school that's
the thing that you learn how to do when
you're in school but as far as teaching
me how to like
make video i really had to get out there
and do it all myself
if you're interested in doing this kind
of thing like you do not need to go to
school you
absolutely can watch the same youtube
videos that i consumed and get some like
bingo quality yeah i was the same way i
learned everything from youtube
i would say now like basically half my
adult life
is just learned from youtube if there's
something you don't know
there's already a youtube video on it
someone's nice and explaining it
not only that but sometimes you could
comment on those old videos like three
years old
unlike niche topics any comment hey i
got a question about this
they'll respond and they get so into it
when you comment on an old video like
that you're like wow someone watched it
from three years ago
um i love it but going back to that
video you scrapped
um i was about to say that sounds like a
really interesting topic
that i think even though even though it
might be a little bit dark
couldn't that still be a benefit to
highlight a potential issue like
what what did you find from that video
because i almost want to learn a little
bit about what's going on
and i feel like it might be important
that's a good highlight great question
yeah well funnily enough i still have
all the research done so the synopsis
for this video
was like an expository uh
documentary style video like an hour
long
minimum about nine youtubers that i had
selected
of course i don't want to run through
the names today some of them are very
well known some of them
not but they were eerily study
they were really similar case studies to
me about
how easy it is to build up a following
and then kind of use that following for
the wrong reason and so
my main thesis for this video was
maybe we can look into ways of
preventing this from happening in the
future instead of just getting shocked
every time it happens
as far as potential solutions
unfortunately i was just more so gonna
make the case of like
you've got to be careful in terms of um
you know kids watching content
because youtube thankfully does not just
you know ban people
left and right which i think is a good
thing that they don't do that you've
kind of got to be
the band hammer in your own um kid's
life just make sure like
they're not interacting just stranger
danger never went away and i think
parasocial relationships in a way
have convinced an entire generation of
children that stranger danger
is not an issue anymore so that's kind
of just where i was going to go with the
video and honestly i really do still
like that thesis so much
i may still see if i can turn it into
something or get something out of it
because i feel like it's an important
point to make especially just if you
look at nowadays the way people get so
obsessed
with internet personalities it kind of
winds up excusing a multitude of sins
and i think
there's interesting psychological
aspects at play but bottom line you've
just got to be careful
what are the dangerous aspects because
the first thing that comes to mind i'm
like
it's advertising it's like it's it's
getting to their emotions and having
them
go mommy daddy i gotta get the new the
merch just dropped i gotta get the merch
and it's like some 80 shirt that's what
i'm thinking
what is the danger from your perspective
maybe i'm totally off maybe it's
something something else i don't know
there's there's a range of behaviors
undisclosed
advertising or just flat out misleading
advertising to kids
is definitely a pretty big one there are
some great videos about that though
already like um
i want to say nerd city perhaps has a
video along those lines
um but in terms of just
the um i guess immediate danger the
imminent danger of the people i select i
had selected
it was more so people who would like
establish inappropriate
creator fan relationships whether that
was through dms
or things like that and so some of these
people
like when they got caught they were just
kind of like oh that's it the jig is up
and i'm like yeah maybe it is
and then other people are just still
uploading and getting hundreds of
thousands of views like nothing happened
and it's just like i feel like people
don't realize
maybe the extent to which this sort of
thing happens
just it's really interesting but at the
same time i was
going to be careful with the video to
not kind of do a repeat of um
i don't remember which adpocalypse it
was or how many we've been through
but do you remember there was that one
scare in the media of like
youtube is running a secret ring of like
inappropriate videos
yeah that was um pay money wubby
did that video yeah it was pay money
wubby and that was like uh
yeah i mean we won't go into too much
detail here but yeah it was basically a
series of videos like
the algorithm was so in tune to what
people wanted to watch that if you
started going down the rabbit hole of
videos on youtube
featuring people who are underage the
algorithm would be like
here's more here's more
and then when you're in it then it's
like then it like hyper focuses
into a community of people on youtube
commenting on underage creators channels
uh inappropriate remarks and like
networking with each other it was
wild it was pay money wubby's video
highlighted this and it was because of
his video
that uh i believe youtube really changed
their policies and that's where they
started like
saying this is this is meant for
children and then if it is
um you can't comment on those videos
they
got very selective about like which
videos are recommended
but yeah it's it's up to the creators i
feel like to bring awareness to these
topics
because you would have no idea um uh
you know even even for for pay money
what like i i don't know how you find
stuff like that but but i would imagine
that youtube like you wouldn't think of
something like that
until it gets brought to your attention
yeah absolutely
well i find like a lot of things that go
on that people just have no idea about
are what happens when you sign out like
i know this youtube is an
extremely different platform when i'm
signed out versus when i'm signed in
because when i'm signed in it's a lot of
streamers
a lot of commentary channels obviously
because that's my niche and so i watch a
lot of that content as well for
inspiration and entertainment
but then when i sign out it's like what
is this website
and why do all these videos have like 15
million plus views and i've never seen
any of them
it's like almost most people
this is not my original idea by the way
i want to
was it true gooden someone has already
done the theory behind this but there
are like bubbles on youtube
and a lot of us are within i would say
like the main youtube bubble we consider
ourselves youtubers or youtube
enthusiasts we watch you know car videos
beauty videos commentary etc anything
like that that you think of when you
think youtube
but there are other bubbles that we
rarely cross over into for example
kids youtube i feel like the majority of
adults are not 100
familiar with kids youtubers which makes
sense
unless you of course you have a kid so
that was another thing too you actually
jog my memory one of the things i was
going to mention
was part of why people keep getting away
with this sort of thing is because
understandably nobody's there to see
what's really going on except the kids
and the creators so when there's no sort
of
like anybody watching and being like hey
this is really weird don't you think you
should call this out
just the most nonsense things wind up
happening but yeah i find youtube as a
whole
just pretty fascinating in terms of the
way the website
subdivides itself every few years into
various communities and the interplay
between them for sure
yeah so it's okay so your danger was
then the relationships that creators
were making
with an audience that was maybe too
impressionable
was that was that yeah for sure like
there's a
there's a range of this right like maybe
um
you've got creators who are just trying
to scam kids with a free iphone giveaway
that's like i would say mild obviously
not good but then if you want to scale
it upward we have like
the austin jones of the world's god
forbid so it's just like anywhere
between there
basically you just gotta be careful i
would say and it's like something i'm
familiar with too just because
i don't have any kids yet but my
siblings for example are a lot younger
than me
so sometimes i'll just like see
what they're watching and i'm just like
wow if i wasn't in this room right now
like no adult really would have seen
this
no one would know like what these kids
killers are popping out it's so strange
do you have insurance um what kind of
insurance media insurance
um no what do you mean oh you gotta get
insurance man
go and get media insurance it's gonna
cost you anywhere from five to fifteen
oh and even fifteen
m i paid twelve thousand dollars a year
for media insurance that covers me
in the event something were to come up
and i say the wrong thing
i think especially when you start going
into those areas
be important to have insurance hopefully
you'll never need it
but the last thing that i'd want to see
happen to you is you say something
about like a creator even if you cover
it objectively and they say you know
what you painted me in a bad light i
disagree with that that's not true
my business suffered i lost out of
sponsorship
and all of a sudden now like you know i
it's you know i'm not making money
anymore
well then they come to you and they say
well you know what i'm going to be suing
d'angelo wallace uh for for spreading
these rumors that
are not true um even if you cover it
objectively and you kind of remember
facts you might want to i just it's a
tax write-off
and it's good peace of mind i like tax
write-offs
yeah i would do it i would do it for the
first two years
uh i did not have any sort of media
insurance and then
when i came out with my video about
apple like i got sued by apple
no way so many yeah i mean that was just
an april fool's joke
but i've so basically i made a video
about why i'm not getting the apple
credit card
and it got like i said yeah it got like
a million views in like two days
and april fools was coming up so i
thought oh it would be really funny if i
made a video
i'm getting sued by apple and i post
that video i'm getting sued by apple
and that video blew up and i think it
got like 700 000 views the first day
on a channel by the way where i think i
had like 300 400 000
subscribers max yeah and i got really
like worried i'm like oh my
like is this bad that i'm like lying in
an april fool's joke
and apple sued me and so of course i
called the insurance company
and uh i was like hey i want to get
media insurance i set it up
they call me back like a few hours later
and they said they're denying me
coverage
and i said what why they said because
you're in the middle like you're getting
sued
like you we can't we can't cover you
after you're getting zombies okay that's
iconic
you gotta watch the ending it was a joke
and then sure enough it's like no it's
fine
but uh still i would say it's hilarious
it's worth it yeah no definitely
something i would look into it wouldn't
be the first time i've had
people who didn't agree with my you know
analysis of situations trying to come
after me
how often does that happen are you
worried about that
um i wouldn't say i'm overly worried
specifically just because i consider it
important to fact check everything
thankfully i don't have any videos on my
channel that
are just like blaringly wrong
information or like i had to make
something up to be sensational so
for the most part i find that people
find it difficult to really
get mad at just me you know showing
here's what happened and here's what i
think about it
but um i've definitely had incidents in
the past where
i guess somebody did not appreciate my
analysis of the situation
and they uh tried to escalate it into
like a weird legal situation but
thankfully it didn't pan out how do they
try to do that you don't you don't have
to say who it is
but like okay well how would they do
they make a video response or
right so you would think or at least i
would think right
first of all people make all kinds of
videos about me
i really don't think like it's my job to
make sure that this person goes
down but let's say i was thinking along
those lines i probably would just try to
get
the video taken down or something like
that that's my assumption
but no instead this individual tries to
convince everyone that i doxed them
um and that i was actually they reported
me to the police i think they explicitly
said that
and that they can't talk about it
anymore because now it's being
investigated but first i want to thank
our sponsor ladder
life is amazing and full of beautiful
surprises whether my ears are being
blessed by my favorite pianist
i'm admiring the inspiring marine life
at my favorite lookout or i'm eating
all-you-can-eat sushi with some of my
best friends it's moments like these
that act as a constant reminder of how
beautiful life is and exactly why it
should be protected on that note it
makes sense why people get life
insurance especially long-term coverage
which is surprisingly affordable why not
pay a little bit each month to protect
the ones that you love
if you're asking yourself this question
choose ladder ladder makes it
impressively fast and easy to get
covered you just need a few minutes and
a phone or a laptop to apply
ladder smart algorithms work in real
time so you'll find out instantly if
you're approved
and there are no hidden fees and you can
cancel at any time and since life
insurance costs more as you age now is
the perfect time to cross it off your
list
so check out ladder today to see if
you're instantly approved go to
ladderlife.com
iced coffee that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life
dot com slash iced coffee ladderlife.com
iced coffee
thank you so much ladder for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
so that was a lot different than hey i'm
just gonna try to use
uh copyright tools to get your video
taken down so i had to go on like this
extended part two of like hey i
definitely didn't dox anyone
i understand you might not have liked
what was in that video but i don't know
why we're trying to go down this path
and of course nothing came of it because
nothing was filed because nobody was
dogs but yeah people
i don't know i just feel like just reach
out to me maybe say hey
do you do you um do you want to have
like open line of communication but yeah
no people really do the most i would say
is there anyone that you would be
nervous to make a video about
or any concept you'd be nervous to make
a video about due to like
legal repercussions legal repercussions
not necessarily well i would have to
think about it because i tend to do like
risk assessment
in the planning phase before i ever
actually commit to a video
so but i don't know in terms of that i
would say youtubers
are kind of good about not trying to
take any and everything down i mean
there's a precedent established
i forget the year but um when matt
what's his name i forgot tried to sue
h3h3 and then that got taken all the way
to court and the president was set there
so
most of the time i don't have to um like
factor that into it because honestly it
probably wouldn't wind up going
well as long as everything is fair use
but that being said i still just try to
be
rather be safe than sorry because like
who really wants the headache of it all
and i do definitely recognize
with so many people watching the videos
it's just important to me that
the content in the videos is accurate
something that stands a test of time
something that people can come back
again because they were able to verify
independently that what was in there was
correct
and that saves me a lot of problems
versus just
an approach of i have to be right and i
have to get this topic right the second
before it fizzles out you know what i
mean yeah do you have people reaching
out
after you make a video on them um i
don't check so
i um yeah i don't really read
my dms or even check my email uh
my manager helps me out with that just
because i don't really need to know
for the most part i would say yeah i've
noticed too on youtube you're very much
right
there seems to be a line between
different creators where it's like you
don't take their video down
like that's too far you can make a video
about them you could call them out
you can get angry but you don't take
their video down that's like the biggest
no-no because they know for themselves
like
how they would feel getting a video
taken down is the same for somebody else
so that's like that's the line
nobody crosses that if you're unhappy
with the video you make a response to it
that's the proper way
even when you two alerts me in the
content
uh not the content id or yeah this kind
of the content id section
and youtube's like hey there's a 100
match
of your video in someone else's video i
still won't take it down
the only time i did was it wasn't a 100
match it was literally just my video
which was still up on my channel someone
downloaded it and put it on their
channel with like
five subscribers and i was like okay
this doesn't make sense so uh um
but no like even if you like watch my
video all the way through
and it takes you two hours and you
include 100 of my footage
i'll just still leave it there because i
understand it's transformative you know
what i mean
like i feel like creators don't want to
be like the youtube bots
because anytime i'm interacting with old
media content like things from nbc
or umg because content id the bot system
is so incapable of distinguishing
between fair use
and re-uploads just everything gets
claimed
struck down blocked worldwide so i just
feel like we don't want to facilitate
that
upon ourselves when it's already just
everywhere if you use any bit of
copyrighted material
what percentage of your videos do end up
getting claimed
not very many thankfully because i tried
to
um proactively edit them in a way where
that's not gonna be a problem
but anytime i do any sort of music
content because i have a few music
reviews on my channel
that's i can just know that's gone like
that's not something i'm gonna make
money from
also i do a lot of live streaming and
every single live stream that i upload
to youtube gets claimed and half of them
get blocked
which is why um very counterintuitive
well because
on my twitch stream i just react to a
lot of content
like for example on the twitch stream i
might say hey i was on the ice coffee
hour podcast
let's check me out there so obviously
like watching a youtuber's content i
know i'm gonna be fine
but then if i'm on stream like hey look
at this snl skit it's relevant to
today's topic
oh yeah they're horrible kevin did an
snl skit
i think it was like a two-hour long live
stream and
uh i think you watched them for like 15
seconds
the whole gosh it was like blocked in
countries the whole video was
demonetized
they were so bad for just a few seconds
in the background while he was talking
over them
i yes snl was definitely the biggest one
that jumped out to me because i was like
this was a very short video in this six
hour live stream
how does this facilitate blocking it
worldwide but
hey them is the rules apparently so
again i just try to work around them
instead of you know
running into that wall but um it's just
such a hassle i can definitely
understand why there's like
an unsaid etiquette like just leave the
video up don't be someone else's
headache in that regard
yeah so when you were making these
videos were you going to college
full-time how did this transition for
you into a career
so i graduated college in 2018.
yes i always have to remember and um
i had 3 000 subscribers that was like
the last sub count i remember having
while i was in college
and it was interesting because i had
just started
getting like traction because i remember
telling my friends like um isn't this so
weird
i didn't call myself a youtuber because
i didn't have a bunch of videos on
youtube
i had just put one there and i was
telling my friends like look this video
has over a thousand views
isn't that so interesting and we were
all like yeah that's so cool
because we weren't youtubers so it was
just like funny that one of us
had gotten like a crumb of youtube
engagement and then i just remember like
walking out of the cafeteria and my
friend
brandon from the other side was like you
have 3 000 subscribers now
you're famous joking of course because
3000 is not that much
but i remember thinking that seems like
a lot
it was kind of in that moment when i
realized okay
if i went from 36 subscribers to 3 000
subscribers
i want to see what the logical extreme
is and now of course
we're approaching um what 2.5 million or
something like that
so it's been all uphill from there
thankfully yeah so were you
just how often were you making videos
and what
what grew your channel so quickly
i would say initially it was the
consistency so right after college
having graduated with honors um with my
bachelor's degree
of course i immediately got the job at a
gas station unironically as one does
and the whole time i was there i said to
myself you know what
and maybe this was dumb but instead of
like
trying to force my way into this
industry whatever nebulous
industry you're supposed to enter after
college i was like
i'm just going to make this youtube
thing work so
simultaneously while i was working part
time at the gas station it was about 32
hours a week
i was working full-time youtube and
making like
nothing and i said to myself the very
first month that i make the same amount
of money
or more from youtube than i'm making at
this gas station job
i'm quitting and i'm going all in even
though it's already going all in there
were several nights i didn't sleep
so i did made that decision in
february i want to say it was february
of 2019
i was like 2019 or 2018 time is not real
but either way i made that decision
in february i remember that and by april
just because of the sheer amount of work
i had done hitherto and the fact that i
had uploaded
six weeks in a row i made enough money
that month to justify quitting my gas
station job and then from there
i've been fortunate enough to get like
you know
brand deals and different partnerships
and of course ad revenue and now
looking back at my life i can see that
if i tried to go
throughout of like i'm out of college
i'm gonna apply to every studio in my
city and i'm gonna
you know go up the chain i would not be
here where i am right now so i'm very
glad i did what i did
wow how many subscribers did you have at
the time of going youtube full time and
quitting your gas station job
now that's a good question let's find
out
if you don't mind me to show you guys
one second
hold on so conveniently i used to say my
subscriber count at the end of every
single video
in that specific time and i can see
right here i had 111 000 subscribers
when i made the decision like that's a
lot that's it
yeah definitely it's the thing about
like sub count
views and monthly revenue is it
fluctuates wildly the reason i don't
like really pay attention to social
blade in terms
of like how much estimates other people
are making is because so much of it has
to do with cpm
and frequency more than anything like if
you have a hundred thousand subscribers
and you're uploading every single day
and you're getting
50 000 views per video okay well then
you're definitely going to get like what
is that over a million
uh views in a month you're definitely
gonna be making some but because i was
only really able to upload once a week
um and the videos were not the kind of
content that gets like the views i'm
getting now
it just wasn't unnecessarily enough to
justify plus my cpm used to be pretty
bad
that i never was able to put my finger
on um it's definitely gotten a lot
better
i mean i don't have you know finance cpm
by any means but um
we were able to pick that up off the
ground but yeah right at um
april 8th 2019 was the very first video
i uploaded
immediately after quitting my gas tasted
job and it felt good because i was like
this is it now and if this goes away i'm
gonna have to walk right back down the
street and so there while i find another
job it was very interesting
that would be a funny title for hours
the day
d'angelo wallace quit his job i don't
know
that's good well yes i like it i like it
you want to do some play on words
we got to figure out something on that
so can you talk a little bit about
like uh how your income is broken down
now
like can you can you share how much you
make on it on a video like that
um it fluctuates so wildly it's almost
pointless to
track for example i have two videos that
have the exact same amount of views
and one of them has precisely half the
revenue of the other so
it's pretty goofy but an easy way to
break it down
just from my experience is um
you can estimate that per 100 000
views you may be netting um
one thousand dollars so for example if
you get a million views maybe you could
be like oh
uh five figures right there that's the
baseline that goes so that i can plan
like business ventures like okay if i
upload these and i'm gonna get this
amount of views
maybe i'll make this much but then we
went into crazy issues like
videos getting demonetized 19 days after
they were approved by youtube or
clips i didn't realize were copyrighted
just
completely negating any revenue
potential
i had but yeah in terms of just like
if i had to break down an average i
would definitely say like 10k per 1m
is the easy analysis got it
and then you're also now doing sponsors
in the videos
definitely is there any other uh income
source that you've that you found from
through youtube yes twitch is an income
source as well
um it's like not a super big one that
one's mostly for my enjoyment because
i like live streaming and um like for
example i know people make a lot of
donations
or they make a lot of money via
donations on twitch but i capped my
donations at five dollars because
honestly i'm just there to have fun
but if you um if like the things i send
to my cpa
are the revenue i'm getting from adsense
which is pretty substantial
brand deals which thanks to my manager
being like super on top of it this year
it's kind of scary has become much more
substantial than it was before
and um twitch is now social revenue
um not through ads though that's one
thing no one talks about i guess because
like
no one wants to be that guy but i would
go ahead and complain
twitch ads are terrible they don't pay
i don't understand why twitch lets you
run ads
like i'll run an ad during a stream and
then realize
i made like less than one dollar off of
an ad run with over a thousand viewers
it's so strange
so that's negligible but thankfully we
still get twitch revenue through
um subscriptions and other things like
that um
that should be yours it would be video
twitter
like twitch ads are terrible terrible
yeah
must be stopped me complaining about
not making enough for ads and i have
like five ad breaks in the video
ads have gone too far
out of control ads
and why they should go away forever no
but i mean it would be great
it would be the best thing in the world
if obviously i was keeping
all the money that i'm making but
obviously like what with me being
self-employed
taxes are pretty substantial just
got into the wind despite everything i
do to make sure that i being as
efficient as possible
working with my cpas giving me all these
tips like no don't do that you're
so dumb please do this instead i do all
these things and then it's still like
the money evaporates so there's that and
then of course i'm paying
um editors and a moderator
as well as well as my manager like
there's honestly i
spend a lot on the business itself
because if i don't treat it like a
business
then it's not gonna run like a business
and that's not gonna come in handy
in the future right now i'm very lucky
i'm extremely fortunate that
i can kind of theoretically i guess
upload anything and get views is one way
of looking at it
but i understand that's not gonna be the
case forever so i'm really just looking
at it as
how can i maximize where i am right now
and build a foundation so that in the
future i can transition
into more eclectic projects and still
maximize the potential of those as well
how many people do you have on your team
um off the top of my head it depends on
like what you consider like for example
my manager is definitely on my team as
well as my two editors plus
um i have one staff moderator though i
do have other moderators on my team
and then um so i guess you could say
those are like the four core people in
terms of like who's actually being paid
but then outside of that i have my whole
moderation team they're just like
a flawless moderation team they keep my
twitch stream running so well
of course i have my cpa as well i have
um people like from
you know how you get like a partner
manager via youtube they reach out every
few months
i definitely consider them to be you
know they don't work for me but we
definitely work together as well so
there's a lot of people who do a lot of
things to make sure that things go
smoothly for me so
i'm appreciative and because of that i'm
able to just try to get out the most
consistent and most quality
uh product that i can how much would you
say that cost you every month
um i try not to think about that but
in terms of just like who's getting paid
what
it's definitely five figures for sure
okay
no matter what happens and that was a
big that was a big commitment i made
at the beginning of this year because i
was like am i gonna can
am i gonna commit to paying other people
um a total of uh five figures a month
that means i'm gonna have to make
substantially more than that every month
which means
i can't stop and i was like but you know
what i like the
idea of like not being able to stop i
like i like the idea of like supporting
other people
and having a reason to do this because
the worst part of being self-employed
is technically not having a reason
there's real no really no impetus when
like you're your own boss it's like
yeah i could upload today or i could
just stay in bed
and not not do anything so structuring
it the way i did it was an extreme
overhaul
at the beginning of this year was very
intentional just so it could facilitate
me being in a place to treat this
the way i should which is just you know
stay on topic
continue to provide quality otherwise
people are not going to want to watch
and just most importantly like more than
anything have something that i can look
back and be proud of we've uploaded an
absurd amount of videos this year
considering the quality level and i can
look back at all of them and be like
yeah those are all really good videos
because i had people helping me and
because
you know i did the things i was supposed
to but 5k
or five figures yeah do you do your own
editing
right now or no for the videos that you
watch
yes the very long videos
no one has ever like touched a single
file of footage for those
other than me but my other channel where
i upload multiple times a week
those videos are i have a my two editors
for that and then i upload a couple of
them but i try not to because it's
inefficient
that reminds me very similar of uh my
main channel it's just like
it's i want to see 95 me and then jack
and i will convene at the
usually either before or after uh i film
a video about like titles thumbnails
but yeah all the editing planning all of
that is uh
is all me and i've always wanted to
maintain that and then jack
does the second channel uh alex's is now
editing the pod this podcast
hey alex hey
so yeah would you ever give up the
editing privileges
of your primary channel your your
long-form content channel or is that
something that you want to do forever
um i definitely would not trade that
over just because i feel like
and this is maybe not something i should
feel like but i think
a lot of the reason that that channel is
successful is because people kind of get
the vibe that it's just me
it's just something i'm very passionate
about and i was able to
transition that into a video and of
course there are like
the most talented editors out there who
could absolutely bring my vision to life
um and they do for my other channel as
well but it's just a passion project
that's something i've come to the
conclusion of like
sure i could treat this like a for it is
business
but i could treat it like it's just a
business and i'm just a businessman
and every out waking hour of my life has
to be efficient
and nothing should be done that someone
else can do but i
really been teaching myself like
honestly passion is a big part of
longevity in the first place so just
because i am so so passionate about the
videos i go up there
i probably i foresee myself doing all
the editing
do you think i relate to that you could
see yourself burning out at some point
in the future or have you
created such a good balance that you
think you could coast on this for
forever
um i've done it at some points in the
past already for sure
um as far as burnout goes it's it's an
interesting concept right because in
many ways
i do consider this job to be easier than
other jobs i've had but then
at the same time i also consider it to
be the hardest thing i've ever done
which i feel like is hard to explain
because like as like a youtuber or
influencer or whatever people want to
call you if like you start talking about
my job is difficult of course you know
you get shut down but i feel like
if i'm like careful about explaining
what it really is that i find difficult
and where the burnout comes from people
understand a large thing i think
is just having other people
that you're responsible for because
that's what happens when you are like
employing people
and for context i am 22 so
i'm obviously you know fully grown man
but at the same time
i'm not that old in terms of like having
all this business
experience to necessarily match the
level that the business has gotten at
so that's certainly something that um
weighs on me from time to time
on a good day i'm just like i'm
fortunate enough to be able to support
all these people
on a bad day i'm like oh no if i don't
perform
it's a bunch of people who are not going
to get paid that doesn't seem right
but um that's one factor that can
contribute to burnout
another is just trying to be too good if
that makes sense because first of all
like
you're never going to be that good you
know like you've always just got to do
your best but you can't turn it into
like a high art form so
the periods of time i can look back
where i was just getting obsessed with
having quote unquote the best videos um
definitely has led me to burn out but i
just remind myself
people are not watching me for the best
videos or because i'm the smartest in
the room or anything like that i'm not
it's just because they can tell i put a
lot into it you know what i mean so
because i've experienced so much burnout
in the past i take
precautions to avoid it in the future if
that makes sense wait hold up for a
second
um you said you're 22 yes and you
graduated from college in 2018
yes how did this happen because i
started when i was 15.
um just about to turn 16 in it was yeah
august because that would have been fall
august of 2014 entered college it was um
it was about what you would expect from
a 15 year old stream
hold up hold up so how did that how do
you do it like
did you just watch high school yeah you
straight up just you went straight from
like
middle school middle school to college
how does that like did you go from
eighth grade to be like all right i'm
going to college
well i was like fortunate enough to not
have a traditional
grade structure if you will because i
was homeschooled
so instead of just like yeah that's it
yeah efficiency
yeah they could speed up through a lot
of that so anyway so explain that that
whole process then
so the main milestones that i guess my
parents were looking for in terms of
like
are you good were can you pass the sat
because obviously that's the entrance
to american college so i took the sat
once and passed it
and um i was 15 because you can take it
at any age i feel like that's something
not everyone knows like
you don't have to have um quote unquote
finished any
um grade if you will you just have to
meet the requirements and then you can
take it
so i took it initially and it was
definitely good enough to get me in
but i said and i would not do this today
by the way this was just me being like
a cocky 15 year old i was or maybe i was
14 i don't remember
i was like i can do better i was
i was like i'm going to take the sat
again and i'm going to get a perfect
score
on the reading section and i took it
again
i did not get a perfect score on the
reading section
but i was only two points off or
something like that it was before they
had
yeah it was before they changed the
structure of the test like if i
whatever my score was like 1700 or
something like that doesn't mean
anything because shortly after me taking
it they
changed it and i think the highest score
is like higher than that now
but it was a pretty darn high score i
was very like
lucky enough to get through that and so
that was enough to get me into the
honors program and they were super
excited to have me so the college helped
facilitate a lot of that as well
honestly though like i don't consider
myself like oh i'm super smart and you
know i was 15 years old doing a
bachelor's program it was more just like
i can just narrow things down to what
i need to take from it if that makes
sense it's the exact same thing i do my
youtube videos which is why people watch
them
so instead of just being like i need to
have all the wherewithal
of an 18 year old which of course is not
very much i can say that now that i'm in
my 20s
i was just more so like how much do i
actually need to know to do well on the
sat
and that's what i took from that and so
from there forward it was all
you know funny games did you get your
ged or you just your parents
sped you through like every grade
instead of spending a year you're
spending like seven months on it
yeah basically the way the requirements
work in my state is like
it's a full graduation thing because
texas is pretty lenient
which is like either good or bad there's
a lot of interesting things that go on
um in terms of homeschooling but my
parents were just
so gosh darn efficient they were like at
the end of each year they just took a
stock of like okay
what level are you with this and do you
think you could pass this and if i
couldn't
they didn't push me into it they were
like okay so this year we're gonna work
on this
so like for example i remember one year
was kind of like an essay workshop
because obviously essays are a pretty
big part of um the college experience
so i came out of that like writing a
mean essay which
unironically i would say still
contributes to my videos today because i
can write
a mean video in a very short amount of
time um
and i remember one year i was like
stocking up on math
credits as well just because it's like
you know you got to be able to do
the little bit of math that's used
because my parents like went to college
so they
understood it's not the way it's
structured people make you think you
need like
every single credit from every single
class that way you can be a fully
functional adult
you don't you just need to take the
required courses and take everything
from each one that you need
and then just move on with your life so
that's kind of how i survived college
who are your parents i want to know
about them what do they do
yeah um funnily enough my dad has the
exact same job just not on youtube
it works for me basically exact same job
he's on
he's a commentary channel yeah oh gosh
his name is ethan klein i've been
kidding imagine
if my dad was a commentary channel he
would probably have more subscribers
than me
because i think he's i think he's
funnier but
the thing about that is um my dad
just knows video that's
from my understanding as a son that's
all he ever did
that's all i ever remember was just like
he was editing something
and um even now he works for a bank
and he does internal video stuff for
them which i didn't know banks had
internal video teams and so like i
showed up at his job and like he took me
through all like the computer rooms
where they have and i was like wow
video is universal and this was before i
was even thinking about being a youtuber
i was just kind of like i guess shown
the power of like video content to
convey ideas
and how you can go anywhere in life but
you're always going to need somebody
to film it in some way shape or form
like no matter what it is
schools need videos for presentations
banks need videos to show
their internal teams etc and then so i
would say the main thing i got from my
dad was just like
an absolute love of all things video
like even now like what i'm submitting
you with this sony
a6600 and we got a short sm7b it's
pretty clean
it might be peaking a little bit because
i need to work on the um distance but
i'm obsessed with that and i definitely
blame him um as far as my mom
she the main thing i got from her was
just
efficiency she's just so smart
like i know people say like i'm smart
and i appreciate it but legitimately
that woman
is just scary smart she can look at any
sort of
problem i mean she raised me so she
could definitely look at problems and
analyze the best way of dealing with
them
and um just from like a young age
instead of i guess like me going to her
for everything she would always help me
but she would always explain
ways that maybe i could have approached
myself as well and that was such a good
blend because i feel like so many
parents they either
do it for you and you don't learn
anything or like they force you to
figure it out or you
and you still don't really learn
anything but because my mom had this
like
i'll help you but i'm also gonna walk
you through it i've always just
believed i can tackle any problem that
way and it's definitely
true so shout out my parents for like
the actual rock solid foundation i've
been able to
scale it upward into where we are today
and hopefully on to bigger and better
things
what do they think about what you're
doing right now and you quitting the gas
station job
were they upset you left the gas station
of course they were upset you left a gas
station because
from their point of view their point of
view was like
you have a job and you're working at a
gas station even though you have a
bachelor's degree
why are you exiting the job force why
are you exiting the workforce
and i was like uh don't worry about it
because i knew i knew
like how much money youtubers could make
even though i was making
i made a thousand dollars by the way
that was the number
in one month where i was like yay i can
quit
it was not very much so with like some
extreme
extreme budgeting i um when i told them
and that was my mistake for saying
yeah my um i'm just waiting until i make
the same amount of money from the guests
because they knew how much that was so
they were just like why would you quit
a job when you just made kind of not
enough from youtube
but having been analyzing my own
analytics for so long
i was just like every time i was just
like just wait just wait just keep
watching
and i was kind of telling them like hey
i kind of made twice as much
this month as i did before and they were
like skeptical but now fast forward and
it's just like
hey i just signed like a five figure
deal again
and now they just they understand why i
quit the gas station job
were they were you worried or were they
worried about you
um being homeschooled and not having
that like socialization of like
going to a school with all your buddies
around or whatever oh oh
yeah yeah yeah i always hear and i
understand i understand that
i'm concerned but honestly i just got
out of the house so much i was fine
like we would go to the park or like um
just to various events
and i never felt like i was starved of
attention
or friends or anything like that part of
that too is because i wasn't an
only child maybe if i was i might not
have had anyone but
trust me the house was never empty i had
no shortage of like
friends either just um it was fun but
yeah just
there was no real like bump in the road
i guess it was a natural progression
from
home school into college it was very fun
you know i take it on college
you're not gonna you you weren't living
in the dorms right or were you
no i was i think i was too young
i don't know if it would have been
allowed did you go to any college
parties
um no honestly even though i'm sure i
wasn't quote unquote allowed to
i wouldn't have went into anyway i was
extremely like
kind of cutthroat in college like i got
there and i
gravitated towards this friend group and
um maybe i shouldn't admit this and so
at the end of the semester
i took stock and i was like how much
time did i spend with these people
and how much did we all accomplish
together
and i came to the conclusion it wasn't
enough so i dropped that entire first
semester friend group
um nicely of course and i kind of found
my core crew and they were all people
who were very similar to me like
we were people who it was a miracle that
we were going to college you know what i
mean like
sure my dad obviously has a degree and
my mom i think spent some time in
college as well but it's still a pretty
big deal that
i was the first person to really get
like
a bachelor's degree from um a university
so
it was important it just i did i didn't
feel like
i was allowed i guess you know to like
mess around now me being slightly older
i completely understand
it wasn't the end of the world i
definitely could have stood to have some
fun
but um there was no shortage of it with
my friends because like our idea of fun
was like we're gonna all
finish this godforsaken essay um that
none of us care about and then we're
just gonna watch
youtube interestingly enough we watched
a lot of team four star i remember at
the time
wow was youtube something you knew you
always wanted to do or when did you
decide that that is what you wanted to
pursue
i it just came from me always wanting to
make videos you know what i mean
i my only regret is that i don't have
every single video i've created
because i feel like i'm trying to scale
them up so high in terms of quality
i would love to like look back at where
i started but the main one i remember
the main one i remember
and i was definitely 13 years old
because i just i remember having just
turned 13
it was quite the riot as the 13th
birthday is i had made a fake
advertisement for visiting niagara falls
a very
a very teenager young teenager thing to
do because it was like
no money to be made off of it i was just
like this is funny i can download
pictures off the internet and put them
into video this is insane
so i created like this fake
advertisement i
i want to say that my dad shared it in
some capacity
i don't remember how but even just a
little bit of
engagement if you will i was like hmm
very interesting
so i've always showed the videos that
i've created to my friends
even before the youtube channel that
people know me for either one
was in existence there was a different
youtube channel that i would upload
videos to
um and that one wound up getting less
than 200 subscribers but still just
some subscribers as well but it wasn't
even for like
public consumption i was just leaving
the videos public and sending them to my
friends because they wanted like
art advice it was just but yeah i would
say more so than always wanting to be a
youtuber
i have just always been driven to create
things and i feel the most fulfilled
when i work hard on something
it turns out the way i want it to and
then i can see that people are
getting some form of enjoyment or
entertainment or education or
enlightenment for it then i'm like
yay i'm here for reason and i did what i
was supposed to do we should talk about
some drama now
probably we need some views i know
when's the david dobrik video coming out
i feel like that's
right that's the yeah that's the next
isn't that the hot topic
um interestingly enough i'm not
releasing a video about david dobrik
um i know from like a business
standpoint that's a very strange thing
to say
but the reason i'm not doing it is
because
i've recently been kind of the same
thing i did
after my first semester of college where
i took stock of like who am i hanging
around and what am i getting for this
i really realized i can still make all
these valid points i have to make
but some people in some situations are
just so
played out i don't necessarily have much
to add to it you know what i mean
i know like i literally know deep down
even now if i just went back
on my word and just put up a david
dobrik video anyway
it would probably get seven to 10
million views initially
it might have 15 in a year or so but the
problem
is it's right back to what we were
talking about initially like
is my heart in it no i think most people
know
what the situation is you know what i
mean um
i think everyone knows what the daily
doping situation is
even though i have points to make about
it i was happy to make them
you know kind of on the stream outside
of that and that's not the only
situation either
uh there's him for sure i know james
charles is uh
going through it if you will as well
just
there's a list of people now that i try
to think
if i don't have anything to contribute
is it possible that i may actually be
losing something
not financially obviously but of myself
from you know diving too far into this
and that's definitely part of my risk
assessment before
videos now so you just like being first
to the chase
like with the huge ground breaking no
you can't because no but he but
he was saying earlier it's like you got
to wait for like the dust to settle
so you can get all the [ __ ] so it's
my biggest video series which is
not online anymore but my biggest video
series
um i made a good
one month after the whole situation
ended
and on top of that one of the videos in
that series
focused on something that had happened
like a year and a half beforehand
i would say i it's some sort of fluke
which i will forever be grateful for
but i am kind of able to still bring up
older situations
and have people watch like once a series
i'm very proud of
is my um paul brothers series because
that wasn't just another
i don't like logan paul video i actually
did like an analysis
there's a lot of storytelling about my
personal opinion of how logan paul has
evolved a little bit and it's kind of
underrated
and um that was just like old news
though
like for me it was more about the story
i liked that video a lot
and uh what's up yeah i did i i watch i
would say probably
of of that main channel of yours i
probably watch i've seen every video
uh at least going back like a year and a
half um yeah that's where all the good
ones are
right uh but i remember watching that
logan paul video
and initially going into it being like
okay he's gonna be a hater
i'm not gonna agree with some of these
points maybe he's changed and
but i i remember watching the video and
thinking like you you were very fair
and it was very you covered every
perspective you covered all the sides
and i walked away thinking like
you know what maybe you went into this
with a bit of an agenda or like you had
some preconceived
thoughts of where this was gonna go but
you had the humility throughout the
throughout the video
to kind of shift your perspective a
little bit and and i thought was very
fair
thank you well that's the thing i don't
like
need to be correct i just need to be
right
like more so i don't always have to have
the last word
i just need to know that i gave the most
fair interpretation of the situation so
that i can feel good about it
and yeah i was like bro this is easy
paul brothers i'm gonna get some views
nobody likes them but the more
the more i dug into logan logan paul's
channel specifically i was like
this is freaking fascinating
like i am obsessed more than anything
with
like growth for myself of course but the
inspiration
from my personal growth comes from other
people i would say more than anything
just because i haven't had that
experience so like
looking at him just come from where he
was to where he is now
instead of just seeing like random
internet dude bro that everyone hates
number four i was like
this is crazy this is like a small town
kid he
just got everything way too quickly
didn't know what the heck to do with it
made the biggest mistake in the world
for that week anyway
and then instead of just i guess
embracing his new villain era he
took that as like a signal that he could
change things around
and now if it takes stock of where he is
and the kind of ideas he's putting out
there i find myself agreeing with a lot
of it
i like you know where he is of course i
don't agree with everything that dude
does but i was like
i was like even though i would still get
views and i still give the video a
negative title by the way because i
didn't need the views but even though i
would still get views and appreciation
for just like
trashing look and fall for 45 minutes to
an hour i was like
maybe people will be receptive to the
same journey i went through
in terms of research and thankfully
people were a lot of people were like
no i'm not i'm still not a fan this is
nothing from me but there are a lot of
people were like
wow i never thought of him like that and
that was really like a teachable moment
for me i was just like
oof i have a lot more power then i
realized not something i gave myself but
i can be mindful i can tell other
versions of stories that we're all
familiar with
would you make videos on on positive
topics and
like highlight good uh in a sense that
like because right now it's leaning into
like and i get it the negative aspect i
i if anyone who understands that the
stock market falling
does ten times the amount of views is
the stock went up
i get it um do you do you have this
uh the same mindset is that it's it's
easier to lean in with the negative and
then change perspectives
or would you ever do a video like
highlighting let's say like
mr beast goes and does you know donates
blah blah blah like would you ever
do something like that i really just
look for
points i can make more so than like
whether situations good or bad
the point i was going to make with of
the populace initially just wound up
changing
so far of course and that became a
journey in them of itself
but i have like a few videos on positive
topics
they're not the ones that i'm known for
interesting of course not why would i be
known for those
i have a couple of really good album
reviews on there on my other channel i
did like
just a whole um it was obviously shorter
video but like about dolly parton and
the things i like
there but as far as just like me like
doing the exact same process
to a more positive topic i don't want to
give too much away but i've been toying
with the idea of just going off
on this really obscure obscure thing
that nobody cares about
because the thing is like you've got to
experiment first of all i'm very
grateful to have the subscribers and the
views i have
but if i just keep doing the same thing
over and over and it's like bad thing of
the week number four
sure i'll keep getting that but am i
gonna get any growth from that no
because clearly that's one thing i can
do well
so i want to make a video where i bring
the same level of
obsession with detail but to something
very obscure i just want to see how many
people i how many people watch it
and what they think about me what is it
we want to know um
i do i i don't want to say because then
we'll bleep it out
deal okay okay perfect bleep it out
alex okay i want to upload
wow you know what that's it that's
interesting
i don't know if it would hit with me i
would okay so you know what i'm going to
tell you from my perspective and this is
this is now your non-audience i'd click
on this
and if it doesn't hook me in the first
minute or two i'm out
uh because it's not a topic that i would
be intro but if you hooked me
after a minute or two i'd be like all
right let me give this five minutes if
i'm still hooked let me give this 10
minutes and then after like 12 you got
me for the rest of the video
i would say no worries i would love a
video
no worries i i always go through that
reverse engineering process
just because i understand i would say
more than the first minute
like the first 30 seconds are
it no matter how many sponsors i have
well
it's only everyone for video no matter
how big the sponsor
is or how many topics i'm talking about
if you don't provide some sort of road
map um
or just even a teaser of what to expect
or some sort of
flash or appeal i i tend to lean into
the flash aspect
like i will edit this like banger intro
i'll download music and i've got like
the um instrumentals going off with the
audio clips like something you would see
on netflix
just because i need people to be like i
see that you've chosen to spend an hour
very
interesting i spent a lot of time in
this as well so we can like spend this
hour together
so yes were i to do this sort of topic i
would absolutely treat it with the same
like
hey i'm gonna respect your time because
i'm just grateful for one view let alone
however many it's gonna get but also
you're about to see how much time i
spend on this as well
i feel like it's it's so infectious
wow um what other what other topics
do you think you might want to talk
about that you would want to bring light
to
that maybe people don't know about or
like issues that you see
doesn't need to be youtube related it
could be something probably something
outside youtube or something that you
see where it's like
that might make a good video i don't
know about that but this is an issue
that i think is worth
bringing up i guess if i was to make
some sort of like
like the last video i would ever make or
the most important video
i would ever make that i don't see too
many people talking about
i would just want to upload a video
telling people like
what it's actually like to be a youtuber
if you will
because obviously the only thing people
see is like um
well this is the only thing people can
see it's like a box basically which is a
window
into your room you know we have a play
button we have some cool stuff
studio lights but so much work goes into
it
so much money of your own pocket money
is involved
so many feelings and experiences and
relationships that you have to form
as well and um it does affect you i feel
like
because i had no idea and i only ever
saw people playing video games or
talking about funny videos
i was just so wildly unprepared because
so many people want to be youtubers
understandably
i would love to just spend the same
amount of detail like
outlining how it's been for me things
you might have to look out for you know
why a lot of it is as good as it seems
and why some of it
is not that's definitely something i
feel like people don't talk about enough
and i understand why again people are
not
i guess receptive to having the magic
broken because then they can start
feeling
alienated very easily but i feel like
the majority of the
problems i experience as a youtuber just
come from the fact that i
am not a youtuber i'm just a person you
know what i mean anyone in this
situation would probably just have
similar feelings there's just so many
things that don't get
solved i guess by having your dream job
and that's kind of what i would love to
make a video about
where do you take it from here in terms
of
just general do you want to continue
making youtube videos for the rest of
your life oh
that's a great time
i tell everybody politics you gotta you
give me
a good voice for politics i think people
would vote for you
that's that's true actually forget the
policies i could deal with
i could deliver them very compellingly
you could you would
you would do your policies through like
a one-hour youtube video
yes wait like that's kind of not a
terrible idea
and you would and you would just you
know demolish all your competition by
putting it together
absolutely i'm uploading a reaction
video to your speech tonight look out
for that
reacting to that be horrifying no that
would be so
good yeah imagine videos and like coming
out with your own hit pieces
of just like why you shouldn't vote for
the other person coming yes
i would love that oh gosh i would so
watch that
no um as far as what i'm going to be
doing in the future certainly not
youtube for the rest of my life i will
probably be uploading videos
to this platform in some form or another
just because
this is where i put my mp4 files
that's how it started off before i had
any subscribers and that's how it'll be
no matter how many people are there to
watch them
but i definitely do have i would say
bigger
um projects on the horizon things i'm
trying to work really hard behind the
scenes with like a team of people that
i've brought on
because i want to create
just other things for people to
experience i'm really really really
glad and fortunate i've just been
too lucky it's almost a little
suspicious how well this has all worked
out for me but because i've been given
this opportunity
i can i'm gonna do the same thing i did
when i had like 3
000 subscribers how far can i take this
so all manner of um
upcoming content whether that's like
fiction instead of non-fiction
whether you see me i don't know on the
bigger on bigger screens than youtube or
anything like that or behind the scenes
anything like that or just things i've
been working on
for a while now and once i'm finally
ready to kind of debut
where i've been headed with this i think
everyone's gonna be quite excited for it
but
even if they're not i've only ever
needed what i've only ever had which was
just
the will to create these things and
enough people who are interested
in seeing what it was i have to say this
time where
are you saving your money now that
you're making i'm investing
all of my money as far as investments
i have a lot of it stored away for
investing in the future but i'm
trying to secure a house first
just before we start looking into like
putting money into
um other places not like anything crazy
i'm not moving into a tick tock mansion
but after that yeah i'm definitely gonna
look into ways of diversifying
everything that i have to make my money
work for me because after you have a
certain amount it's like
there's no reason to run out ever again
and i'm like oh wait a minute i might
kind of be getting there so yeah i'm
bringing on advisors for sure
got it you don't need advisors you don't
need invite i mean
i have my dad that's advisor number one
two and three sure and then
my cpa helps me as well okay maybe just
one other individual got it so so you
say you're saving pretty much all of it
is that is that the truth
almost all of it just gets yeah it's
like
you would think i sell drugs
that's how much money i that's how much
i just leave the money in the account
and don't touch it
if you stumbled upon it you would be
like what's going on here but again
it's just there for a split second
because i gotta get um these bigger
purchases of the way and then yeah i'm
gonna look out what can i do with this
some of it's gonna work for me
some of it i'm gonna invest right into
my bigger projects
um i can start additional businesses
other than the one i'm running right now
um i just it's like the sky's the limit
it's very exciting stuff but yeah as far
as like spending
i'm just not a big spender like my car
for example
is uh i don't think it's a bentley
bentega
yeah well no it's it's it's a royce no
it's um it's a chevy impala 2019. nice
it's nice it's not the best ever it's
like not even a tesla
oh is it the sport is it the ss
no it's just yeah i um first of all i
don't even do enough driving for that
but yeah as far as like paying for a
lifestyle that's something i've
completely opted out of so like
the money i'm able to make kind of winds
up going a long way for me which i'm
very fortunate it gives me
more to like put into the projects i'm
excited about and stuff like that but
yeah i um
i happen to not have expensive taste
which is a cool combo with
making some cash every now and then how
many credit cards do you have
um not too many my credit score is
actually
this isn't like doxing or anything i
guess but my credit score is excellent
according to credit karma um it's it's
barely
if i like do one wrong thing it might
drop back into good incentive excellence
is it but yeah i've been killing it 50
above 750
yeah barely higher 753
yes yeah and we're going to get it up
higher than ever
yeah it's it's our running joke that
everyone has a higher credit score than
jack
how much dogecoin do you have um
one million that's pretty good actually
yeah
like you could have bought a million
dogecoin not to like you know
six months ago wouldn't have been that
much yeah actually it wouldn't because
it was less than a cent right
yeah i bought in a less than half it was
a third of us yeah i
actually probably could have bought a
million jeez
but um you bought in
a thousand so you got like
two 220 fifty thousand yeah yes quarter
million nice
gosh man uh
i was about to ask something what was it
about the end i wanted to ask
how methodical and like analytical were
you
in growing your youtube channel or did
you just kind of have an idea like i'm
just going to put out as
you know the best possible content it
doesn't matter when just whenever it's
done
and you just post it and you had like
grow through that or were you very
analytical with your
with your stats and stuff like that and
posting dates and times and stuff it was
a
it was a mix of things the beauty of
youtube's algorithm being an algorithm
are that there are pathways within that
to replicate and predict success
and there's also a level of random
numbers just being thrown everywhere
controlling who gets seen where so
it's not very random i'll tell you that
it's certainly not as mystical as people
seem to think it is so
yes a lot of the youtube success i would
absolutely attribute to just me
being cognizant of what i was posting
when i was posting and how
i was presenting the content in a way
that maximizes
um viewers but
me getting like over 2 million
subscribers now
a lot of that did just come from videos
just popping off
i was like i made a good video and it
just went
way crazier than anyone could have
expected which i'm very
lucky and um so yeah i can't like take
credit like yeah i
from day one knew i was gonna have you
know two million subscribers by this
date
i was just more like yeah i'm probably
going to be able to continue an upward
trajectory and then like last year just
it was just went like this yeah
oh this is the question i was gonna ask
do you think jack
should sell his dogecoin um
to me yes okay at a discount probably
so jack put in a hundred dollars and
it's now worth
15 grand fifteen thousand dollars
i'm telling him to sell don't you point
it's not an all-time high no you know
there we go
i'm sorry cell doesn't sound like hold
to me yeah it's a it's a weird spelling
of hold
yeah thank you that's what i thought
what would elon musk say you know what i
mean if elon musk was sitting on that
couch
right across from you would you really
look that man in the face and say i'm
going to sell my damaged coins you know
what that's actually a great point thank
you for raising stuff
so right now for reference at the time
we're filming this it's 64 cents
and nice
i this is it's tough for me because i
remember
us uh filming a podcast a year ago
almost a year ago like exactly almost
where it was trading at
0.03
cents each and i put a thousand dollars
in it
and that today would be worth i think it
was a hundred and fifty thousand
hundred and fifty five thousand
immediately after the podcast was over
i'm like that's stupid i sold it
oh no
i would have turned a thousand into 150
i would have made
uh like three times the amount that this
podcast has made
over the last year from 60 seconds of a
joke in a podcast
that hurts so bad i feel like when time
travel
inevitably gets invented it's not going
to be
nasa it's not going to be some offspring
of neil degrasse tyson
it's just going to be someone who's so
determined to go back in time
and invest in the right crypto and
stocks
that they pull this off if if that
existed then wouldn't we
now be like receiving people coming from
the future
like yeah not if they were very careful
about it because here's
so here's so here's uh here's an
interesting thing that uh that someone
was talking about on reddit
and the concept was if you could go back
10 years from now and you would have a
choice to go and invest in bitcoin 10
years ago and you knew what it was going
to do
but your future wasn't guaranteed would
you go and take that opportunity
and the topic was like absolutely i
would go and i would invest in bitcoin
back then
and i would get to relive like the
greatest moments of my life
and i could have all my friends invest
with me
and we could all be mega wealthy and our
lives would be great
imagine this is a movie though where
somebody today goes back 10 years from
now and somebody today by the way who
has like an amazing family
they have a happy job they're living in
but they just want like
hey i want to help out my family and
like and have all this money and be able
to help everyone else around me but they
have a loving family
imagine if they went back they bought
bitcoin
but somehow by them buying bitcoin or
like one little action along the way
caused bitcoin to become worthless and
now all of a sudden that because they
bought bitcoin
they didn't meet the love of their life
they didn't have
their family they screwed everything up
along the way and not only that
but what they came back in time for is
now worthless
imagine that as a movie imagine that
and just the whole that's that's the
that is i think that would hurt my
feelings yeah i think he wants you to
make a movie
about this no i i just thought that
would be that would be such an
incredible movie because it's not what
you would expect
uh you would have to find a way for this
to be like uh you know for there to be
some sort of happy ending
but uh yeah you know how would you
resolve that i guess you would have to
do it or something like that i don't
know but but he presses the weight go
back button
but no it's an interesting thing that
even if you were able to go back in time
for certain things
just want like you'd make the wrong turn
on one street
and maybe because of that someone gets
delayed from their job and because of
that they get fired and because they got
fired they started the business that
competes with
like there's just so many different
things that i think could happen it is
crazy to think about
i mean even in context of my own life
it's
exactly like that what if the one video
i put up
was one of the many videos that was just
on my pc i'm like eh
i'm not going to upload that like right
this second i'll do it when i come back
home
and then i didn't i thought it was a
crazy moment yeah
crazy moment free i've actually never
shared this uh ever
uh when i was i was probably just
i was i think i was 18 uh years old and
i
this was right before i sold my first
house as a real estate agent so
maybe like six or seven months in doing
all these leases
but uh i i think i i got onto the show i
think it was like entourage or something
like that
i think i think it was one of those sort
of shows and
for like a week i thought like you know
what i haven't sold a house as a real
estate agent i'm going to be a talent
agent
and i'm going to be able to represent
like celebrities
and so like during my down time late at
night
i was sitting there writing an email to
like the top
person at caa and now for those that
aren't aware like
in order to be a talent agent you either
need to have a direct
like connection or like be kind of like
born into that sort of family
um or you have to work at the mail room
and then you work your way up
it's it's very much one of those
business you don't just start out as an
agent you gotta work your way up
so i like i got the top person at caa
and i had got their email address and i
wrote out like this
really detailed email uh basically
pitching myself of like why i wanted to
work with them and why i would be like
the perfect person for that position
and uh i i was about to send it
uh but the guy i was working with at the
time came in the office and this must
have been like 9 30 10
and uh he brought his son in with the
office
and uh his son must have been like four
or five years old at the time
and goes in and just presses the off
button
on the uh not not the monitor but like
the actual computer itself
the whole computer turns off and i was
like
i spent all this time doing the email
and like right yeah and then of course i
turn it back
on the whole thing is gone no draft no
draft
nothing i don't know what happened oh my
gosh
and uh i was like you know what i'm not
going to send that email i put so much
i was so like i was like
i can't put because i couldn't recreate
that like when you're in the mood and i
was like
i was just like fed up that i didn't
sell a house and i was just like
i put my heart and soul in this email
right this is my chance
you can't you couldn't i couldn't get in
that same mindset again to write that at
the same caliber
and obviously now but but part of me
wonders what would have happened if that
email had sent
and i had gotten a response back and i
had
chosen to leave real estate a month
before i would sell a house
to go and work as like some talent agent
and maybe that didn't work out then i'd
have to go back to college and like
so that was one of those moments in the
moment i was really upset i'm like oh
why did you come in
but like looking back that might have
been like that saving grace for me where
he just turns off the computer and this
is like
fate being like no graham nope you're
not
sending that email but i wonder like in
an alternative universe what would have
happened
maybe nothing maybe just that email goes
on red didn't matter anyway but
it's fun to think about i have enough of
those moments where i can say yeah this
is definitely one of those
but it makes me wonder how many of those
moments do i have where i didn't know
that was even like that big of a deal
right like something small happens and
i'm like
but then that could have been
life-changing i always believe that
and this happens all the time and i'm
sure this happens to everybody but
sometimes they're like
i love my phone inside like you know you
get in the car i don't have my phone
and then i go back inside and look for
it for a minute and then i'm on the
freeway and then there's like
you know the whole bunch of traffic and
then you look at your phone it turns out
there's an
accident that's like a minute ahead of
you so many times i'm thinking like wow
had i left a minute sooner i would have
been
right where that accident was so i don't
know
but i always believe that i always
believe that like any time i'm delayed i
never get upset because i'm like
for some reason this is like the
universe telling me i need i need to be
looking for my phone and like delaying
me for some
that's always that's what i think i
believe it i really like it
d'angelo uh i just want to know what's
your opinion on the content cop series
i mean first of all it's iconic you know
there's nothing to deny there in terms
of its
sheer impact on the commentary
genre on youtube um have they withstood
the test of time it's hard to say
i mean some of those videos are what
five
years old six yeah i remember like
just by the time i watched them i don't
think they had all come out yet
but a bunch of them had and i watched
every single content cop and i of course
not being ingrained in youtube culture
was like this is insane
there's this dude just dropping bombs on
all these crazy people
not knowing that's kind of where i would
wind up in very short amount of time
but um i just think like idubbbz was
ahead of the curve in terms of youtube
commentary for sure
i know a lot of people have a lot of
opinions but um
they're just funny videos you know what
i mean i really consider like
hey and h3h3 in their prime
to have just kind of really set the tone
for a lot of things that are still going
on in commentary youtube today
part of me doesn't know if that would be
if if if idubs were doing the same
videos today if if that would be
acceptable i almost feel like that
you could get away with that stuff five
six years ago but today
for sure it doesn't have the same
punch to it like it would back then
because yeah back then no one was doing
it
making these 30 minute long you know
whole like displays
uh that was big but now i feel like
uh you know has it been watered down a
little bit
um you know i'm sure if you made a video
everyone would watch
it i would love it i would love it but i
don't that but i think if anything
he'd have to be more careful today back
six years ago he didn't say whatever he
wanted to and it was just it was good
but today it's like like i'm watching
some of his old unboxing
videos and i did that like seven months
ago to to do a lot of research and like
i i don't know how he was able to get
away with saying the things he did back
then
even as a joke you couldn't do that
today
well i just think i know there's
definitely like a debate about
youtube's changing culture but i just
follow the money
i'm just like of course things are
getting more and more sanitized because
honestly advertisers have more and more
money to bring to the table
and the bigger the advertisers get the
stinger they are which is why we wind up
with like
you know various levels of youtube
monetization coming from different
advertisers
so whereas i of course would find it
funnier if i was just able to say any
and every joke that comes to mind having
to temper things to stay within
a reasonable um you know realm so that i
can make sure i'm still maximizing my
own reach
i i'll allow it for the adsense yeah
it's tough for me sometimes because i do
want to make some like some edgy jokes
or like you know
say some dirty jokes that you know some
people might be like oh that's
that's that's in a that's pg-13 but yeah
i've done my best to maintain
as as clean as an image as i can because
uh yeah i just want to be family
friendly
and yeah it works out in the long run
more than anything right
i would say like individually from video
to video i'm just like
ah i have to cut this out because i
don't think it comes across the way i
want it to and then
it might not work but if i look back at
the amount of times i've done that i'm
just like oh i'm so glad i did that
because
now i have a whole um back catalog of
content that works for me instead of
against me
riots i just want to say
what idubbbz did with the content cops
was a little different though
i feel like even today in youtube's
landscape it would be pretty tolerated
just because of like the the lasting
impact those videos had on you i
remember like i would watch those videos
and i would feel
so great afterwards but then i watched
someone else's like
expose video like for example leafy is
here like i
i would binge all of his content but
still even after like watching those
videos that i loved it would still leave
somewhat of a bad taste in my mouth
you know what i mean which i think is
just entirely different to
to idubbbz content cause which i yeah
but i do some of his videos got removed
for bullying
well yeah
that policies are changing and it's and
it's kind of scary too that they could
go back
and you could make a video today that
that complies today
but that doesn't get grandfathered in
that you could make a video
it's fine but three years from now
something changes they could go back and
say oh that we don't allow that anymore
it's it's a little scary for sure
and that's why i'm just diversifying and
forging a
path that leads to opportunities off
platform
because i definitely see it's just it
wouldn't be a problem if things didn't
change so much like if you look at
traditional tv
old media things change over decades
so for 10 years maybe you're allowed to
do this but then
someone's super bored and they write a
new law now oops we've all got to change
over to this new format
and so you can very slowly and
deliberately
track changes in etiquette or even just
like technical specifications like
i remember when everything had to be hd
for it to
air before that was the case but um with
youtube
it's just like surprise we have new
guidelines
and half of your videos are not
following them and it's just like
what that huh what is what is promoting
all of this
so yeah instead of just trying to get
too caught up into all that i'm just
like
oof what is there to be gained from the
situation for me
it's mostly just the connection i have
with the people that are here so i will
just make sure i facilitate being able
to get the content out to them
as efficiently as possible you know if
youtube
gets in between that i will just find
other ways of doing it you know what i
mean
yeah did you get your free stock down
below in the description when you sign
up for public because it's worth
all the way up to 50 dollars wait
are you serious where's the link again
down below
in the description oh snap well i think
after this
amazing podcast i should follow that
link and get my free stock
yes because it's worth all the way up to
50 dollars
thank you guys so much for watching i
really appreciate it and angel thank you
so much for coming on this this has been
the best surprise
i feel like every episode jack you
should just surprise me with somebody
how am i supposed to run up this i don't
get mr beast next
but seriously guys thank you so much for
watching if you guys like episodes like
this
go and destroy the like button go and
subscribe
because it's totally free you get to see
an episode every single week and then
daniel we'll link to all of your
information down below in the
description
go and check out this channel watch
these videos they're absolutely
incredible
and uh
ever episode of the iced coffee hour